amazingly the 2020 election cycle is in
full swing at this point virtually every
notable Democrat really in the world has
already jumped in
president Trump looked vulnerable a
couple of months ago maybe even doomed
to defeat and that was of course the
lure that got them into the race but
things have changed a lot in the last
two months the Democratic Party's own
woke miss has been the real factor watch
an agency like ice which repeatedly and
systematically violates human rights
does not deserve a dime this
administration and this president are
truly morally corrupt mama look you won
bullies don't win baby they don't
because we're gonna go in there so what
would happen if the least balanced most
extreme members that ever kradic party
took over well the president couldn't
have scripted better he may not have
built a wall in the end but his enemies
are so terrifying to normal voters that
it's helped him his approval rating is
rising his reflection odds have improved
as well author and columnist mark Stein
has been watching all this and joins us
tonight so I'm starting to think that
maybe Alexandria Cascio Cortez and this
elon Omar are working for the Trump
Organization in some capacity I mean it
almost seems like a setup it's it's just
almost too perfect yeah I think they're
colluding with Trump as we should say we
need to investigate it yeah basically
what is gonna happen now is that the the
trajectory in the in the Democrat side
of the field is that they're all gonna
they're all going to drive each other
even more woke so you'll think that
Elizabeth Warren is woke and she'll make
Kamala Harris even more woke and in the
end there
even succeed in Woking Joe Biden and
they're all going to be made super hyper
woke federal officials policemen in
effect have discussed using the 25th
amendment because they think President
Trump is mentally ill and as Alan
Dershowitz said that's a judgment that
should be made by doctors or secretaries
or chiefs of staff anyone in fact by the
police agency and the question before
the electorate is going to be who is
really the sane or the insane one yeah
the party that is proposing retrofitting
every single two hundred and thirty year
old colonial era farmhouse in in
northern New England in order to make it
compatible with the green New Deal the
party that is committed to abolishing
the border enforcement agency or the guy
who's just there in the White House
doing his job
even as he drives deep state lunatics to
devise ever more absurd ways of trying
to get rid of him
so you've got a wonder if there aren't
big parts of the Democratic Party even
the Democratic Party we're gonna look at
people like this screaming on CNN all
day and think you know what this is too
much for me I mean they could
potentially break their party in half
yes I think so because if you if you
look at what happened last time they had
a problematic and frankly rather
unlikable candidate proposing proposing
relatively centrist or left-of-center
policies in Democrat terms this time
round you are going to have candidates
who are taking extreme leftist positions
and the risk of course is as with what
happened to Alan OMA that you in in
crude identity politics terms they check
all the boxes they do all the virtue
signaling so they seem kinda nice and
then you read three or four their tweets
and you realize actually this person
isn't nice and I think that's the real
danger for the Democrats was Trump
comparison plays a sort of thug and a
bully and he tweets up a storm but he's
actually not unlikable in the same way
that some of these Democrats are
revealed and his policies are basically
moderate which nobody ever says but it's
true yeah no no that's that's absolutely
right he's relatively centrist on that
stuff for sure by the standards are two
years ago anyway mark Stein thank you
very much for that appreciate it thanks
a lot Tucker